alors je n'ai pas reconnu une forme
d'échec je sais bien que nous avons une
tendance à adorer les mea culpa
non j'essaie d'être lucide beaucoup de
gens considèrent que quand on est
volontaire on ne doit pas reconnaître
les situations telles quelles et ça veut
pas dire pour autant qu'on se bat la
coulpe et qu'on ne regarde que le passé
donc j'essaie d'être lucide nous avons
réagi moins vite que les états unis
d'amérique
c'est un fait après je ne reconnais pas
d'échec parce que nous avons corrigé
très vite ce retard donc nous avons eu
un retard c'est vrai ne si je n'osais
pas vous le dire aujourd'hui vous me
diriez à juste titre vous manqué de
lucidité et cela prendrait sans doute
moins crédibles les propos que je vais
ensuite tenir mais je dis simplement
premièrement nous l'avons reconnu
réparer on a mis en place un mécanisme
de contrôle à l'export nous ne sommes
plus naïfs 2 nous l'avons reconnu
réparer nous avons accéléré la
production en europe et 3 surtout moi je
veux insister sur un point
l'union européenne a mis sur pelé sur
pied une politique industrielle
d'ampleur pour atteindre une capacité
qui est de l'ordre de 2 à 3 milliards de
doses par an d'ici au deuxième semestre
de cette année ce qui veut dire que nous
serons en capacité non seulement de
combler nos besoins mais d'exporter
massivement et dans la durée pour nos
propres besoins européens
nous allons livrer au deuxième trimestre
360 millions de doses
près de 420 d'ici mi juillet je ne
demande pas dans le détail on pourra le
faire si vous le souhaitez ce qui nous
permettra d'atteindre potentiellement
notre immunité collective continental
c'est à dire que ce retard qu'on a
constaté en début d'année nous l'avons
combler très vite dans les semaines qui
ont suivi ce qui nous met en capacité
d'ici à la mi-2011 21 de produire pour
nous mêmes et de produire suffisamment
pour protéger nos concitoyens et bâtir
notre immunité collective